you have to make 50 returns your money
like if it costs you 2 million to open
you got to be able to make a million and
profit year one otherwise it doesn't
work the model does not make enough
money in terms of return on capital for
it to be interesting for an investor
it's simplifying it's removing stuff if
you really want to model Chick-fil-A
they have one quarter of the amount of
menu items as any other fast food
restaurant if every month for the next
year you say I need to add one and a
half percent or two percent to this
margin this month I'm going to find two
percent next month let me find two
percent next month I'm gonna find two
percent by the end of the year the model
will be way Tighter and then the thing
is is when you get the model really
right you won't want a franchise